Hey, this may be the best video I've ever
seen of Pedo or Rourke as you know, that Oh,
failed big at the time.
First Democratic debates, and he has no chance
of being the Democratic nominee.
But that doesn't mean all hope is gone.
He finally showed some signs of life in the
last 48 hours when he was asked about Donald
Trump's rhetoric being connected to the recent
shootings and Beto O'Rourke, who is normally
subdued and not necessarily super inspired
or high energy, immediately high energy.
And I love it.
Let's take a look.
Yeah.
Is there anything in your mind that the president
can do now to make this any better?
What do you think?
Um, you know, that he's been saying he's been
calling Mexican immigrants rapists and criminals.
Um, I, I don't know, like members of the press,
what's the hold on a second.
You know, I, I, it's, it's these, um, it's
these questions that you know, the answers
to, I mean, connect the dots about what he's
been doing in this country.
Um, he's not tolerating racism.
He is promoting racism.
He's not tolerating violence.
He's inciting racism and violence in this
country.
So, um, you know, I just, I don't know what
kind of question that is.
Good for him truly.
And then he appeared on ABC's this week also
bringing the energy,
you just said, uh, that the president is fueling
hate in this country.
Are you suggesting that he bears responsibility
for what we just saw in El Paso?
I am because he does, um, someone who describes
Mexican immigrants as rapists and criminals,
uh, who has sought to ban all Muslims, all
people of one religion, from traveling to
the United States.
And then here's Beto on MSNBC.
Morning Joe, even more fired up.
I mean, the president has not been shy.
He's not been saying this behind closed doors.
This is out in the open, you know, all people
of one religion inherently defective and should
be banned from the shores of this country.
The only modern Western democracy that I can
think of that said anything close to this
is the Third Reich.
Uh, Nazi Germany.
I'm talking about human beings as though they
are animals, making them subhuman to make
it okay to put their kids in cages.
We, we've lost seven children in our custody
just over the last year in this, the wealthiest,
the most powerful country on the face of the
planet, saying that he wants more immigrants
like those from Nordic countries, the widest
places on the face of the planet.
Um, this president, his is open.
Some is also an invitation to violence.
We've seen a rise in hate crimes every single
one of the last three years.
So Joe, you're, you're absolutely right.
The writing has been on the wall since his
maiden speech coming down that escalator describing
Mexican immigrants as rapists and criminals.
The actions that follow cannot surprise us
seriously.
Like with no sarcasm whatsoever.
Good for Beto.
He has no shot at being the Democratic nominee.
He's got some strange things in his delivery.
You can often get himself sort of confused
about his own answers, but he would be a great
senator.
I wish, as I've said before, that he would
leave the presidential race and try to knock
off John Cornyn in Texas who's up for reelection
in 2020 not particularly popular and imagine
replacing a republican red state senator with
Beto or Rourke.
That would be a really good use of better
or Rourke's time and fundraising power.
Beto is actually really good when he does
what he did here.
He just says what he's thinking.
He's not rehearsed, he's not doing campaign
talking points.
He might actually even be doing better in
the Democratic nomination field if instead
of doing that thing where he pauses to think
and he's trying to, you know, seeming to want
to answer for himself.
What am I supposed to say here?
If he just said what he felt this actually,
if you think back to 2008 it sort of happened
with John McCain.
Much of what gave John McCain has favor ability
in 2008 and in the lead up to, uh, participating
in the general election after winning the
Republican primary was he was thought of as
a maverick, whether it's true or not, but
that was the perception.
He said what he thought.
It didn't feel calculated and even if you
disagreed with a lot of what he said, it felt
like genuine McCain.
But then as McCain became the general election
Republican nominee against Barack Obama, he
sort of went into that talking point, robotic
answers feel calculated sort of thing, and
he lost a lot of his appeal.
Beto is at his best when he's passionate and
off the cuff and just channels the voice of
the average voter against the fiasco of the
Trump era period.
This is not what he's been doing at campaign
events.
This is not what Beto has been doing at presidential
debates.
The poll numbers reflect that he's doing absolutely
terribly.
He gets called on hinged by right-wingers.
That's to be expected for this.
A, a impassioned rant, but who cares truly
this Beto, this angry Beto.
This is the most likable Beto that I've ever
seen and I still think that there is something
to to uh, explore there and going back to
Texas and running against John Cornyn who's
up for reelection in 2020.
Good for Beto.
Uh, he's emotional, he's not unhinged, and
he's right to be emotional.
Given what's going on.